bonjour bonjour pour cette leçon
aujourd'hui avec jean baptiste bonjour
jean baptiste bonjour stephen bonjour à
tous alors qu'est ce que nous allons
voir aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui ils ne sont prévus sur
la partie espagnole et espagnols qui est
très connu qui est très à la mode
bon on l'appelle espagne où est ce que
tu sais série lopez série lopez qui a
développé les fondements de cette
ouverture au 17e je crois bien alors
c'est alors les progrès si c'est plutôt
16e en fait un seizième 16e fin du 7e pc
ce religieux espagnol la cour de charles
quint carlos pinto
c'est un moment aussi l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs qui plonge comme ça des racines
très ancienne de notre histoire
bien sûr il est des ouvertures qui sont
vraiment vieille comme le monde c'est le
cas de la partie espagnole
donc c'est vous lopez a aussi écrit
beaucoup de choses sur son nez sur les
finales sur la stratégie en général donc
cette partie espagnole qui a bien
survécu qui qui est même comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
remise à la mode
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
qui pensent que sur tous les grands
tournois je parle des trois de très
forts grands maîtres on a des des
parties dire à 50% qui sont des partis
espagnols ont alors beaucoup de granby
marche elle ouais ça soit une mode en ce
moment extraordinaire sur le combi marc
schalk est une sous mario qui est une
variante de l'espagnol on fera une leçon
bien sûr consacré à ce grand marché qui
est très intéressant qui lui aussi est
moins vieux mais quand même
mais qui n'a quand il ya un siècle voilà
qu'elle a quand même un siècle on voit
que les variantes je vois il ya un
siècle par marchal lui-même sont encore
à la mode c'est ça que l'extraordinaire
à noter que ces deux partis cela nous a
fait aussi l'objet d'un des plus grands
matches puisque la route car pauvre
surtout kasparov et karpov
olivier rooney que tu as beaucoup reçu
pour de banales tv était le second temps
de karpov
pendant ce match est bien sûr et il est
intarissable sur la d sur la partie
espagnole
quand on les écoute parler de sas et
c'est vraiment très réjouissant parce
qu'il ya tout un tas l'idée c'est une
voiture qui est très riche vraiment très
riche tout autant qu'une sicilienne
beaucoup de stratégie beaucoup de
tactique
le thème positionnelle qui sont valables
dans toutes les ouvertures du jeu
d'échecs alors on va voir ça tout de
suite avec notre échiquier partie
espagnole qu'on conseille évidemment
débutants puisque c'est sur un début
ouvert donc on se consiste souvent à des
numéros débutant
oui en fait à un débutant on lui
conseille des roquelles plus vite
possible
l'espagnol on ne peut pas rouler plus
vite normalement donc 101-101 cavaliers
en sort un fou ont fait leur plan
allemand ça va très vite
non madame en 4e 4,5 ou 5 voix
caractéristique alors là c'est c'est
moderne
je dirais c'est vieux et c'est moderne à
la fois le fait de mettre le pion depuis
en noir en face du pions blancs
maintenant je pense toutes les
ouvertures de même une rupture avec des
quatre et on considère logiquement
maintenant que c'est le plus sûr moyen
pour égaliser la partie par contre c'est
parfois ce qui mène à des positions
aussi mitri consignes symétrique n'est
pas peut-être pas plate alors là bas on
va voir car les f3 donc logique
on sort le cavalier en essayant de faire
un gain de temps puisque on attaque le
pion s'en voit rien donc le meilleur
qu'août développement ces cavaliers c6
ce qui aurait laissé 6 voilà on protège
tout simplement le clan il ya d'autres
possibilités mais c'est pas la partie
espagnole
là on va s'approcher la partie espagnole
et après fou mais ça y est voilà ça
c'est le coût de la partie de pagnol
c'est cette pression du fourbe et cinq
sur le défenseur du pur 9,5 alors ce
cavalier effectivement défend et puis on
essaie de le fou fait pression menace
immédiate serait d'envisager fou prend
cavaliers voilà huit cavaliers prendre 5
je dirais que la menace latente c'est de
supprimer le défenseur suppression du
défenseur éprise du pion en 5
alors on sait que c'est pas possible
tout de suite on peut regarder peut-être
le troisième coup on a commencé à parler
déjà de cette possibilité cette
possibilité parce que les noirs ne
l'empêchent pas les noirs ne l'empêchent
pas et je dirais même l'incitent ça veut
dire sur a6 on peut se dire bon on est
venu pour ça on pourrait prendre
et alors si on prend vous prend
cavaliers c6 est bien en cas les c6 des
processus que les noirs prennent du
plomb des vous faites pour ouvrir la
grande colonne ici de la dame
et si les blancs si les blancs prennent
en est simple c'est bien on a un coût
qui récupère le pion tout de suite qu'il
est d'un des quatre syndicats dont attac
à la fois le cavalier et le pion en 4 on
peut pas défendre les deux donc après
cette astuce qui est très connu
eh bien j'ai eu le taux de monde de voir
que ça a été jouée au très haut niveau
aussi récemment par etienne bacrot avec
les blancs donc les mêmes là dessus il
ya de la théorie pour ce qui est
pourtant on pense que c'est pas grand
chose pour les noirs d'ailleurs etienne
a perdu la partie mais c'était c'était
pas du ct pas dû à l'ouverture
mais voilà en tout cas un élément ne
craignent pas de le perdre le pion aux 5
alors on peut prendre en c6 des
processus sans pour autant prendre le
pion aux saintes la position est
intéressante et ce sera aussi l'objet je
dirais desous variante d'espanola on a
dit parler du marshall on a aussi la
berlinoise et le troisième coup
cavaliers f6 et on à la variante des
chances de l'espagnol qui ne variante
aussi très intéressante où les blancs
donnent tout de suite la paire de fou
pour un affaiblissement de structures du
pion et on va ensuite oui voilà on va
ensuite échangé le pion des avec le pion
à eux qu'on va jouer des quatre voilà
tôt ou tard on va essayer de jouer des
quatre pour avoir une majorité de pions
e f g h contre fgh qui est un pion au
centre majorité de pions très saine et
qui va nous permettre dans toutes les
fins de parties d'avoir un pur passé
alors que les noirs eux ils ont une
majorité de personnel dame qui comporte
des pions doublé ce qui veut dire tout
simplement pas de purs pas c'est bien
sûr parce qu'il ya un pion qui sert à
rien en gros je crois que le renvoi
spécialistes c'est vrai mais tu pourrais
l'exacte il a beaucoup il a beaucoup
joué ça avec les blancs et maintenant il
je vais beaucoup de parties avec les
noirs parce que c'est un adepte de 85
avec thé noir donc ici on va regarder
l'espagnol classique on fait donc sur
l'a6 aujourd'hui c'est l'espagnol facile
pour ces raisons là en fait on
simplement on recule le fonds est en
fait les blancs vont inciter les noirs
tôt ou tard a joué le coup mais cette
vaisselle qui est logique
oui avec l'idée qu'il est noir vont
affaiblir un peu lors leur aide à un
petit peu ils vont prendre aussi un peu
d'espacés à des contreparties simplement
le fait d'avoir été recalé à 6 x 4 ça
permettra au noir quand la menace de
prise de pions sera vraiment effective
de pouvoir votre b5 et de se débarrasser
d'eux
cette pression du fou sur le cavalier
donc intercalé les coups d'abord avec à
6 x 4 c'est une bonne idée
et puis les blancs sont pas mécontents
de mettre leurs fous en b3 puisqu'ils
s'il sera bien placé mais c'est un fou
qui fait du chemin d'habitude rêve un b3
après les noirs et celle qui prendra
cardia sein qui va se cacher dans une
petite niche en c2 on verra c'est clair
mais si les pions de cartes blanches
avant c'est évident que ça crée des
troubles 115 blanche aussi ça peut c'est
intéressant ça augmente le potentiel du
fonds voilà en tout cas ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai compris la force d'étudier un
peu l'espagnol qui est jean je suis très
loin d'avoir dans l'infini parce que
quand je disais cette très riche mais
c'est que ce fou finalement en b3 il est
très fort c'est ce qu'on appelle le fou
espagnol faire il faut retenir je pense
qu'il faut prendre pour argent comptant
que cette pièce est la plus importante
de la position oui voilà quand on essaie
de vous le prendre ne vous dit pas roms
améliore son cash blanche mon foot cases
blanches ne sert pas à grand chose
ce foot finit toujours par se réveiller
et servent une pièce qui est très
important dans la partie espagnole est
souvent extrêmement puissante
alors on voit la suite pour les noirs
dans l'utah cabaye m6 donc là une contre
attaque des noirs aussi sur le plan de 4
aussi on développe
évidemment le cavalier dans le but du
rock hélas comme souvent quand il ya une
attaque de ce type là sur une sur le
centre et sur une colonne ouvertes les
blancs ne protège pas mais ils font le
rock une prothèse indirectement disons
parce qu'il met en fait il développe la
tour développe la tourache un qui va
menacer d'aller sur la colonie si jamais
le cavalier prend en 4 qui est la
variante d'espagne de l'ouverte donc ça
ne s'oublie aussi la nasa vont se jouer
ça mène un jeu assez assez assez violent
au centre on voit là
je traiterai complexe au centre en tout
cas c'est une façon indirecte de
défendre le pion des 3 à la pause du
petit rock serait un peu un peu dommage
ça serait d'ailleurs le coup voilà le
coût des deux des trois alors c'est un
peu ça c'est un peu dommage pourquoi
c'est dommage parce que clairement le
plan des blancs dans l'espagnol c'est de
parvenir à jour à jouer des quatre avec
le soutien du pion ces trois voies la
forme et ce fameux fameux centre de
pionsat peu passive ce n est pas moi je
le détroit et puis après quand on aura
bien protégé le pluri 4 on va rejouer
décade donc c'est une petite perte de
temps voilà donc petit rock et qu'un
mode irak une meilleure course assez
logique
hélas les noirs le joug le classique
flo7 on développe le fou sur la colonne
comme ça on n'a plus les problèmes de
tours 1
et là on peut menacer avec les noirs de
prendre pied en quatre oui lui ne sera
plus les problèmes avec le roi en 8 le
roi est protégé on n'a pas le retour de
bâton sur la colonne ne donc là ça
devient une menace effective explique le
coup suivant ça explique la protection
du pont alors avec la tour on sort pas
le cavalier pourquoi on ne sent pas le
cavalier armatis tu es bien exactement
pour la même raison que tout à l'heure
ça veut dire que notre disposition que
l'on veut que leur choisir c'est de
jouer ces trois et ensuite des quêtes
donc ces trois et on invite des cas
voilà on verra pas le cavalier sur cette
carte exactement on veut construire un
force entre deux pions aucune tension
ici sur le pion aux 5
voilà qui est quelque chose a acquis une
tension aussi central entre l'entrée des
pions la voilà on a abordé dans déjà pas
mal d'ouverture mais on considère
souvent que le pian c est un pion très
important dans les ouvertures puisque
c'est un pion qui aide à la construction
du centre et que sauf si on y contraint
on ne doit pas le bloquer alors les
noirs ont bloqué au deuxième coup k et
ses 6 mai parce que quand il sait si
c'est de loin le meilleur coût les
autres couples ont tous des
inconvénients qui sont plus grands que
bloquer le plan c'est alors que les
blancs eux ils ont ce choix justement
cette possibilité de ne pas le camion
s'est et ils n'auront pas le faire
maintenant à la première pression venue
ils choisissent le tour en vain donc
c'est très justifiées très justifiées
donc on a protégé le pion aux quatre
avec notre
entre tour ici tout simplement au centre
est donc maintenant c'est des 5 alors la
logique c'était le temps pourquoi parce
que là les blancs menacée maintenant on
a une vraie menace était de prendre de
prendre ce pion ce pion aux quatre la
moto créature sème pardon maintenant que
la tour e protège le plus 4 la petite
astuce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure avec la
dame en d4 ne marcherait pas parce que
cavalier reviendra en f3 et la dame ne
pourrait pas prendre un cadre puisqu'il
ya tour protège donc pas tant il faut se
débarrasser de la pression du faux sur
le cavalier b5 b6 logique on enlève la
pression du fou sur le défenseur du pion
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est
cette promotion dynamique c'est que la
pièce ans et si c'est pas une pièce
statique on l'envoie pas les changer
pour pour un fou c'est qu'en échange le
défenseur du pion oui ce n'est donc pas
une pièce d'un statique en défense un an
en échange d'un défenseur
c'est cette notion là plutôt qu'il faut
intégrer alors four b3 voilà on est donc
là on voit là il est beau ce fou pascal
ory table sur la fameuse case f7 oui
qu'est la case tant redoutée des
amateurs puisque c'est la casse du coup
du berger et c'est le nombre à bhl
fourchette aussi rappelle le coup du
berger rapidement après eux quatre ans
et 4 dames h5 et dans le premier set mat
ouais ça va c'est dans toutes les
parties de 4,5 c'est le talon d'achille
des lois en fait tancer le pion qui est
le moins protégés de toute la position
en tout cas c'est protéger une fois
comme d'autres pions mais seulement par
le roi donc c'est un pion qui est
vraiment un peu faiblard et là on
retrouve ce thème effectivement même si
pour l'instant les menaces sont encore
un peu flou alors les noirs ne rock pas
tout de suite il joue d'abord le coût
des six donc ça c'est intéressant
l'idée pour les noirs jean baptiste say
devenir un g4 alors voilà alors ben
pourquoi pas parce que encore une fois
le plan cc3 suivi de décathlon rappel ce
plan ces trois là regarde sur le t4
et si jamais le souvenir g4 il fait
pression sur le cavalier francky est un
défenseur du puy en d4 et menacerait
tout simplement de ceux de s'échanger
ceux qui auraient le désavantage pour
les blancs de l'un des viviers la dame
du contrôle la case tkd parce que si on
prend être plongée t-rex encore pire
reste le rock et le roi est très faible
et si on prend un cas d'amélie en parle
depuis un an d'écart en tout cas on perd
le contrôle et on est retardée pour
jouer pour le des cadres alors on joue
h3 maintenant c'est une possibilité donc
h3 c'est tout simplement faciale coule
plus vite et ouais impossibilité bras
disons qu'il ya toujours ce débat est ce
que c'est on joue ces trois d'abord
suivi de vache 3 je pense que pour être
cohérents avec l'idée qu'on vient
d'expliquer il faut jouer h3 massue bien
sûr h3 pour empêcher fujikai est donc
préparé cette fameuse poussée qui est le
plan essentiel et blanc de prendre une
petite expérience en attention parce que
dans les débuts avec le 85
attention aux coups h3 quand on joue
trop tôt il faut toujours se poser la
question quand on joue tous en tout cas
il faut toujours se poser la question
est ce que mon adversaire ne va pas s'en
servir pour que ce soit une cible et
préparer une poussée g5 g4 pour ouvrir
bien sûr ça c'est la question qu'il faut
toujours se poser dans ces cas-là si les
noirs le fond il faut donc miser sur le
fait qu'ils vont faire grand roque
donc est-ce que le dans cette position
les noirs peuvent faire grand roque la
réponse c'est non
ici puisqu'ils ont joué à 6b 5 et ça ça
a créé ici d'aider des trous dans cette
position ce qui pourrait arriver en
revanche dans la partie italienne dans
la partie italienne ou dans toute
position en tout cas où les pions soit
encore en à 7,17 voilà h3 c'est un coup
très grave si les noirs ou encore la
possibilité de femmes rock et là ils ont
par ailleurs lancé une attaque directe
ou indirecte
hachey g5 g4 on se retrouve un clouage
désagréable une colonne j'ai ouverte et
on est très malade
voilà pour petit rock on peut tirer pour
les noirs donc la malle en blanc nez
blanc classique baoding on a une
position maintenant
où on a contrôle du centre qui est très
bon mais on regarde et on a toutes les
dames encore qui n'est pas développé
c'est une situation qui est assez
intéressante tout ça s'est pas
développée voilà pour autant on n'est
pas en retard de développement autant de
pièces développées que les doigts
cavaliers foule à tours l2 - quand même
parce qu'il peut quasiment cloud foule
avant voilà sauf que la tour sauf que la
tour est moins active la tour la tomato
f8 aussi hémoise m libre alors que la
tour au loin joue déjà un rôle important
tout à fait voilà donc maintenant il
faut réfléchir à la façon dont on a
développé le reste des pièces et bien
pour le cavalier on a dit que c'était
pas la case c3 puisque ces trois on va
jouer maintenant pour contrôler le
centre et donc on va sortir plus tôt en
d2 en cavale et on va le savoir peut
montrer le chemin des deux afin f1 et
après on aura le choix entre deux belles
kg 3 ou bien et roissy la position il
permet voir un match des fois ce qu'on
veut venir manger 4 des fois alors c'est
vrai c'est vrai que ce plan est très
fréquent dans la partie espagnole
mais le plan cavaliers h2k les g4 en
fait c'est un plan plutôt pour le
cavalier f3 est vraiment me donner un
plus à rien alors que les cavaliers g3
lui a des possibilités oref 5 paragraphe
qui sont très intéressantes donc ces
trois c'est le bon coup et là on arrive
à un carrefour
vraiment il ya une multitude de coups
possibles pour les peaux les noirs qui
sont sur toute bonne on va les regarder
on va les regarder alors on commence par
cavalier à 5 avaya 5 donc là le cavalier
menace ne prendre ce fameux feu puisque
ces temps puisque maintenant qu'on a
protégé le centre évidemment
on menace ici damiens c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure
maintenant le cavalier il n'est plus
obligé de lequel pioncer il peut il peut
le libérer maintenant et il va entre
guillemets gagner un temps sur le fou
qui comme le disait une pièce importante
dans quel blog ne donne pas d'acquis
vont le cachet en c2 voilà voilà
et alors c'est simple parce que
maintenant on va contrôler en contrôle
ici la case des quatre à l'appui en
séjour maxime joue un rôle c'est à dire
que vous contre 7 pouces et centrale les
mains voilà en tout cas on veut égaliser
toujours des forces au sens très bien
les blancs ont aidé le pion à venir en
d4 qui pioncent étroit et alors les
noirs bouche de ses cinq pour que ce
soit un pion de la ligue c'est sûr
contraction de l'ale messieurs alors on
notera que la case des 5 pour être
considéré comme faible sauf qu'il n'ya
pas de colonne ouvert dessus et qu'en
plus le cavalier n'étant pas en c3
allait pas très bien contrôlé par les
blancs donc on peut se permettre avec
les noirs d'affaiblir momentanément ceux
qui ont des six qui est pas tout à fait
c'est vrai mais tu as raison de le dire
d'ailleurs
parce qu'après le coup deux des quatre
que l'on peut et qu'à regarder voilà
c'est une question qui est très
intéressante puisque ici il faudrait
faire attention par exemple à un échange
en c5 pensée 5 ou en outre 5
alors pas trop tôt parce que c'est une
paire de tension qui est un petit peu
qu'un petit peu dommage mais après un
échange et bien honorer une caste des 5
pour les blancs et pas de classe des 5
pour les noirs pas de casse dès 4 ans le
case des quatre pour les noix pardon
voilà donc c'est ça serait que c'est une
question qu'il faut toujours avoir en
tête ça pourrait être un terme pourrait
faire bouger ses échanges extérieurs si
ce qui protège des scènes et
éventuellement est bien là fera la
manade pourparlers carlier des deux
griefs un cavalier ou trois des cinq
cavaliers des deux d'avoir devenir
d'abord en d2 puis ayant 3 si on veut
viser spécialement voilà donc pour
l'instant les noirs ont pas avec quand
même très inquiet parce que c'est une
manuelle qui est très longue et ils ont
le temps de s'adapter
bien sûr mais il faut quand même d'avoir
en tête donc là le coup suivant des
noirs est un coup logique on met la dame
comme souvent dans beaucoup d'ouverture
d'ailleurs pas commencé à aimer
dernières minutes mais tombe sur la case
c'est cette voie là de gaz naturel aussi
pour la dame
oui on a un oeil sur la casse sur le
pion aux scènes tout simplement sur le
pur de sa question le fou ces deux aussi
sur le fond ces deux on a un contrôle
sur la colonne c'est qui est très
inhabituel cavaliers d2 voilà donc
maintenant on peut commencer à
développer les pièces le phocéen je
dirais que tant que l'on n'a pas de
casse vraiment intéressante pour lui il
n'est pas utile de bouger ce serait une
perte de temps
on considère qu'une pièce est développée
quand halak quand même beaucoup de cases
à sa disposition
tant qu'on n'est pas sûr de sa case et
qui reste plus qu'une pièce à développer
on peut souvent se permettre de retarder
un peu de développement
et là c'est l'heure de faire c'est
prendre les quatre maintenant parce que
si on l'avait fait le coup d'avant on
pourrait développer le câble et b en c3
peut-être peut-être et plus vivant on ne
resterait plus vitales et au contrôle
des desserts tout à fait raison c'est
une des idées principales de ce timing
pour les voir prendre mais une fois que
le cavalier est venu d'ailleurs c'est
une technique
c'est une astuce qu'on va retrouver dans
d'autres ouvertures oui on va attendre
que le cavalier sortant des deux pour
prendre en d4 comme ça c'est 3 prendre
les cadres à casser trop à libérer mais
c'est trop tard car il ya déjà bougé à
prendre trop toute façon on est d'accord
pour dire téléphone qu effectivement on
se penche sur les ouvertures précise
mais que c'est ces principes d'ouverture
on les retrouve on essaie de vous les
expliquer on essaye de les retrouver
dans toutes les ouvertures donc c'est ce
sont des mécanismes qu'il faut qu'il
faut connaître c'est un peu comme des
formules
voilà vous pourrez les appliquer après
vous même dans votre partie vous allez
dès fois réussir par vous tromper en
tout cas la réflexion que ça va créer
sera forcément bénéfique
c'est prendrait quatre voilà en
tranquillement a ajouté que tout est
bien protégé pour les blancs évidemment
le temps des quatre le pion à cannes on
n'en parle même pas parce qu'elle a tout
donné et le cavalier donc c'est une
forteresse imprenable
hélas les noirs alors on l'a aussi
encore plein de choix possibles on peut
encore envisagé plusieurs coups même si
cavaliers sait si c'est quand même le
coup le plus logique une fois capable et
ses 6 ans revient c'est si pardon et les
cas fini son office en a 5 il allait me
libérer la fille elle travaille il
revient ces 6es recontrôle la casse des
quatre il ya une menace directe c'est de
prendre en d4 ici tout à fait donc c'est
ce qui peut expliquer la suite alors on
arrive un peu à l'extrémité de
l'ouverture là on va rentrer presque au
milieu de jeunes alors je pense que je
trouve que je considère que qualité si
c'est un bon coup parce que sinon sans
doute que les blancs auraient le temps
de faire la manoeuvre qu'on reconnaît
cavaliere fait un cavalier g3 alors que
là on pose une question options des 4 on
n'a pas envie de prendre puisque la case
des cinq on ne peut pas l'atteindre très
vite en tout cas maintenant les noirs
eux aussi auraient la case des quatre
bâtiments qu'ils ont échangé une réponse
est bien sûr
donc on est obligé de le défendre ce
plan des 4 et pour le défendre il faut
jouer cavalier b33 voilà qui est
clairement le meilleur coup et après on
protégera avec le fou par exemple ici en
23 et on va poursuivre pour suivre alors
oui pourquoi pas cavalier f1 parce que
la dame aussi protège le pion des cats
mais qu'elle en a parlé tout à l'heure
de la dame qui qui a un oeil sur le pion
sur le fou ces deux donc il y aurait une
surcharge de la dame à la fois sur le
plan des 4 alors on va voir cavaler
poids ringarde qu'elle prend du galon et
cas depuis on prend et la maintenance il
est blanc reprennent le pion est tout
simplement c'est le fouquet qui ont
l'air donc on va dire que là les noirs
on simplifie ouverte ils ont égalisé
sans doute que le pion des quatre ne va
pas tenir longtemps mais ça nous permet
d'aborder aussi le thème principal de
l'espagnol pour les noirs c'est que le
temps que les blancs vont mettre pour
récupérer le plan des 4 va probablement
permettre aux noirs de pousser leurs
pions des six en d5 parce que le temps
que les blancs s'organisent pour le
récupérer
on va pouvoir essayer de procéder cet
échange
et dans ces cas là les forces seront
complètement égal voilà
morrow égalise et l'ouverture sans trop
de difficulté donc il faut tenir compte
de ce paramètre
quand il choisit alors ça c'était une
des variantes possibles
on va revenir après le coup ses droits
ouais si on a analysé une possibilité
sur cavalia 5
voilà maintenant il ya d'autres
développements possibles que ce qu'on a
montré ses tenues c'est une idée parce
qu'on peut dans séparant la se retrouver
aussi avec des cavaliers des deux
cavaliers fin et tout mais on peut pas
voir toutes les 27 n'ont que trop riches
ont montré les grands principes de
l'ouverture donc on s'arrête évidemment
oui c'est de son encontre des thèmes
récurrents l'ouverture alors une autre
arme qui a beaucoup hésité
karpov les antennes bien c'est tours 8
voilà là une particularité c'est
proposer presque une partie du en fait
c'est pas prêt ce que c'est d'ailleurs
allemand s'est d'ailleurs nul pour ces
essais quand les joueurs les gros mais
tu décides malheureusement je dirais
pour des raisons on va expliquer
pourquoi pour dire et pour faire du le
salon des pointes facilement sans trop
tatillon gérer un tournoi ou bien
l'arrêter quand ils l'ont raté ou
on peut jouer la répétition de coûts
cavaliers g5 à alléger 5,6 à l'astuce
on attaque le regarder le pion elle
s'était attaquée par le fou par le câble
et il n'y a pas d'autres coûts pour n'y
avait pas d'autres coûts donc de revenir
avec leur revenir ceci dit maintenant on
peut on peut penser que c'est une perte
de temps pour les noirs mais on a et on
le verra un coup pour les marques et
ashes qui est un coup utile dans cette
partie espagnole
souvent les noirs de six mois là à chis
tours 8
on verra plus tard un taureau 8 fuite g6
c'est une autre variante donc barricades
le cavalier peut revenir en aurait trop
fait trois ans qu'on peut revenir il
revient à la position initiale du 9e
goût et on refait tout refait tous remis
ça c'est un peu ça s'est un peu à noter
quoi alors
aussi je vous des quatre mais dans ces
cas là la tourelle va cependant pas
suite c'est une telle situation puisque
la tour va viser le ballon va mettre le
moment il va y avoir meilleure case on
va mettre le fonds en fuite
cette tour va taper sur le soutien de 4
et le foyer fuite peut être on va le
développer par geci ce projet c'est beau
c'est là c'est pas dupe et d'être cédée
cette future alors ça c'est une
possibilité oui alors une autre
possibilité
après ces trois alors un coup aussi très
marrant de cette partie spéciale ses
cavaliers mais huit cavaliers 8
alors ça c'est assez rigolo quoi ça peut
être également je crois que c'est brière
il ya tout un tas de variantes
j'espère que parce que le savoir parce
que ça c'est très technique alors c'est
le cas il revient celle là je suis
quasiment sûr que c'est la variante
breyer
car il ya cinq sa nouvelle laurentide cf
mais malheureusement je suis pas je suis
pas un connard sur les noms de ce
carrefour justement de toutes les
variantes espagnole alors la balle idée
c'est encore une fois de libérer le pion
ses sens alors on veut libyen et on sait
ce n est pas à mettre le cavaly ici
parce qu'on va vouloir remettre se caler
sur 17 voilà ouais donc gt5 ambitieuse
pastilla parce qu'il a un gros potentiel
il peut aller en baisse il peut aller en
c5 volonté ça il va attendre que les
blancs se décide avec leur centre de
pions pour trouver la meilleure case et
puis aussi parfois il peut aussi aller
en fuite rapports protégés loin mais
pourquoi pas existé alors des quatre
classiques cavalli dessel a noté que la
menace des blancs c'est simplement que
tu reprends le sel qui gagnait tout
simplement oui alors jean todt a donc on
a le temps de donc ça explique le coup
suivant car il est 17 jeux vous protège
d'abord le pion et ses cavaliers des
deux classiques car il ya donc bien de
voir les idées fou 17 et la foulée c'est
donc déjà ici on augmente un peu la
pression sur le tube cap qui pour
l'instant est bien défendu ah oui et
puis on ne peut pas jouer carrière et
non on bloque le jeu trajet habituel du
cavalier qui doit rester là pour
protéger ou alors on met une autre pièce
de la défense 2-4 c'est c'est le coût
qui résoud à la partie qu'on vous
propose deux variantes en tout cas entre
les co et crame nique aux mélodies amber
en 2002 fous ces deux fous ces deux donc
là alors à noter que c'est un thème
classique connu et plusieurs fois
déclaré parmi nous aurions surprotège
une case de pions ce sera son talent
libérés chaque pièce est libre de bouger
du coup et oui et quand ce pion va
partir aussi le fou sera très bien placé
puisqu'il va viser la lune voilà et
battante le fouiller plus en b3 et épais
la pression sur elle cette aide on peut
proposer par exemple tours 8
t'aurais mythe voilà et puis on a une
position ma foi assez égal avec toujours
un avantage des espaces pour les blancs
mais on voit que quand même d pour les
noirs c'est de rajouter une pression sur
quatre si lecavalier bouge trop vite on
j'ai des échanges au centre et y aura
une pièce deux pièces et trois pièces
avec la tour quand le four à bois et on
voudrait fouet fuite et puis on veut
jouer soit la pression sur 4 3 des 5 3
des 5 pour égaliser encore les pieds au
centre
donc ça c'est une autre idée voilà c'est
une autre idée alors sur cette position
après le deuxième coup ce c3 est encore
une autre idée alors je vais enlever
maintenant c'est à plein ce parcours
classique du cavalier il ya plein
d'idées mais on vous montre toutes ces
idées qui sont à la limite à choisir en
fonction de votre votre goût de votre
style en tout cas ça montre que c'est
dur pour les blancs de te connaître
donc on peut se spécialiser sur une
variante un peu un peu différente
on n'a rien d'autre cook a été joué dans
la fameuse partie kasparov karpov une
des parties kasparov et karpov faubourgs
huppés du monde de lyon et new york
c'est carlier 17 cavalli 17 alors ça
c'est curieux parce qu'un deuxième
cavaliers en décèdent mais en fait on
surprotège la case de 5
on se pressait la caisse de 5 et puis
sur des quatre sur des 4 eh bien on joue
faux f6 et ça libe la regarder un
cavalier deux cavaliers un fou un pion
ce pion est une forteresse
absolument et donc des quatre est
totalement inefficients voilà et puis
aussi on veut on veut peut-être donné
prendre en d4 pour c'est une pression 4
on a on a déjà deux pièces qui vise qui
vise le pion des quatre cavaliers c6 et
le poète si ce qui appuie le pion le
pion de 5
voilà voilà une autre où il a trouvé
cette foulée 7
après ces trois derniers coups avoir
foulé cette voie là de 4 encore des
quatre tours 8 pour 8 on retrouve un peu
les mêmes coucou il est tout à fait
valide et deux cabanes été deux fois est
floue et suit donc toujours pareil on
enlève le fou passe comme ça la tour par
transparence attaque le pion e4 et aussi
le fou par transparence de cette dès que
le deck le pion aux 5 aura bougé et dès
que le câble et 6 us auront bougé on
voit qu'il ya un maximum de pression sur
le pion aux quatre anneaux a l'intention
est là les blancs ou leucocytes
thématiques dans l'espagnol va falloir
réfléchir à faire à peu près ce que tout
le temps presque à chaque coup faut se
poser la question est ce que c'est le
moment de le faire ou pas c'est le cours
à quatre résistants alors
à 4 effectivement ça aurait été bête de
ne pas en parler parce que c'est un coup
qu'on retrouve quand même assez souvent
dans la partie espagnole alors il y a
je me rappelle de forts joueurs qui me
parlait d'un stage qu'ils avaient fait
avec zaytsev justement un stage consacré
uniquement à la partie espagnole un
stage de quelques jours et je crois que
l'idée directrice qui leur avait donné
pendant tout ce stage c'était une
espagnole ça se joue sur les deux m
c'est à dire que c'est rare dans une
ouverture on conseille rarement jouer
sur les deux ailes conseil j'ai plutôt
de concentrer nos forces sur une seule
partie de l'échiquier ne revienne plus
fort bien sûr alors que
zaytsev qui comme le spécialiste mondial
de toute l'école russe sur la partie
espagnole disait qu'il faut jouer sur
les deux ailes il faut créer des
affaiblissements sur les deux ailes
c'est ça qui va faire céder les noirs
dans la plupart des positions comme ça
un peu de un peu fermé un peu un peu de
tranchées drainantes et qu'on est là au
deuxième coup il ya toujours aucun point
et reste des chats mais c'est quand même
énorme
la complexité est maximale voilà donc à
quatre alors à 4h y comprends pas bien
sûr 1,4 on est on veut pas d'eux des
structures et or jouent à chis parce
qu'à un moment donné on éviter quand
même ses cavaliers g5 qui sont invités
les cavaliers 5 avec l'aide du fou du
four b3 on veut éviter aussi la tête
même des fronts g5 1 qui peuvent être
embêtant parfois énormes attentes et a
menacé le plus effective on a poussé
deux fous ces deux donc là on sous
protêt retour pareil on surprotège le
pion aux quatre c'est toujours quand
même évidemment un pion essentiel et
puis on met le fou aussi sur cette
vérité bonal qui parfois peut s'avérer
mortelle est la leur sort va se détendre
je prends des quatre ans des quatre ses
productions c'est le moment et la
cavalli békalé beckett et celle du pic
elle fout espagnol donc évidemment
l'idée c'est de prendre ce fou c'est de
condom on a dit qu'il fallait surtout
pas surtout pas parce qu'il défend et
protège le point 4 et puis on se rend
bien croquis peur des perspectives
intéressantes sur le petit rock surtout
bien et là on n'hésite pas à le mettre
en b1 souffre ou parce que ce qu'on veut
surtout c'est garder sous fausse ou
c'est très belle diagonale ou à la fois
il protège le pion au 4 mai à tours un
peu con me 4,5 peut aussi créer des
menaces sur la case achète en liaison
pourquoi pas avec la dame
on va très vite voilà donc un match peut
être rapide donc ça c'est là c'est une
autre partie que vous pourrez trouver
entre autres kasparov et karpov
le parti est très longue et très
intéressante mais évidemment on peut pas
recommander les artistes par exemple
présenter mais je vous invite utile pour
la garder dans vos bases de données
comme toutes les parties du match
d'ailleurs fait un match d'anthologie
alors donc on va simplement résumé
maintenant les coûts je crois qu'on a
fait le tour des antillais
a vu beaucoup d'idées on a fait le
courant dès qu'on va revenir un peu le
carrefour de sept espagnols c'est ici
voilà donc il faut quand même retenir
tous les coups précédents parce que
c'est
c'est une mécanique logique quand même
donc il faut quand même retenir l'ordre
des coûts la justification de chacun des
coûts et puis les enjeux et bien après
après ce coup ces trois et on les
connaît maintenant
maintenant on veut pousser des quatre
avait les blancs on veut développer le
cavalier via la case des deux est
souvent la case f1 voilà un fou de toute
façon on laissera jamais prendront le et
trans aide aussi les attaques et voir
éventuellement en b1 et les noirs de
leur côté vont essayer de créer de la
tension deux côtés les dames avec ses 5
et vont développer leur tour au centre
le fou souvent et fuite et le fou si
vite va souvent venir en bessette
alors si vous êtes en régression
sensible c'est un joueur d'attac rapide
c'est pas forcément une ouverture pour
vous parce que c'est une espagnole ces
savantes espagnol pour ça soit d'abord
sur des bases positionnelle solide et
ensuite on développe la tacc si vous la
joie d'attac qui veut sauter à la gorge
leurs adversaires on vous conseillera
plutôt une italienne quelque chose comme
ça mais sur l'espagnol on peut pas
attaquer très vite d'abord on construit
notre centre et quand on a le sens très
bien ensuite les bonnes âmes pour
pouvoir attaquer mais diable mais
l'espagnol c'est une ouverture qui
respecte énormément
le centre ok bon mais je vois là on a on
a fait le tour un peu de cette ouverture
espagne les grandes idées bon après il
faut creuser vie dans chaque sexe ou
variante on si l'om que vous
vous voulez mais c'est rare qu'on puisse
jouer la même souvent rien de plusieurs
fois je dirais que oui mais je dirais
qu'avec qu'avec ça déjà vous avez un bon
petit bailliage pour pouvoir exactement
vous amuser pendant les parties dans
toutes les bases mais coûte merci jean
baptiste pour cette leçon sur l'art et
si stephen très ancien parti espagnol as
he will la rue lopez
merci au revoir au revoir bientôt